patrick henry est sorti discrètement
hier soir de la maison d'arrêt de caen
après 25 ans d'incarcération il a
retrouvé un certain parfum de liberté
peu avant minuit accompagné par le
directeur de la prison personne ne
l'attendait vraiment à sa sortie mais
patrick henry savait qu'elle était
imminente
il y à une quinzaine de jours la
juridiction de régional de basse
normandie lui accorder enfin une
libération conditionnelle
c'était la huitième fois que patrick
henry la réclamait pour un de ses
anciens avocats
cette décision est juste si on ne fait
pas confiance à patrick henry compte
tenu de quitter preuve qu'il a donné de
sa volonté de saurer juteux se réadapter
de se sortir de de cette ambiance
criminels dans laquelle il avait vécu
sur mu peut pas confiance fronde le
frein personnes cette libération marque
un nouvel acte de l'histoire de patrick
henry
en 1977 il était condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour
l'assassinât du petit philippe bertrand
après toutes ces années charles corlet
l'homme qui a décidé de lui tendre la
main en prison patrick henry travailler
pour lui
ensemble ils ont décidé de créer une
société informatique nous sommes dans
l'ère du 21e siècle
je crois qu'il faut être plus ou moins
du lynchage du moyen-âge il faut essayer
de travailler dans notre siècle
malheureusement ceux qui crient le plus
fort c'est un jour qui rompt importeront
un problème avec leur enfant et
peut-être que dans dix ans dans 20 ans
il convainc charles corlet sur la route
film ils iront merci pourtant les
mesures de cette libération
conditionnelle impose certaines règles
patrick henry dormir à deux nuits par
semaine en prison et ce pendant huit
mois il ne pourra sortir du territoire
français et devra par ailleurs se
soumettre à de nombreux contrôles par un
service de probation pendant les sept
prochaines années des règles décidées
par le juge d'application des peines qui
peut au premier faux pas le remettre en
prison patrick henry le sait pour rester
en liberté il devra se faire discret et
surtout prouver qu'il est devenu un
homme fréquentable
et